une procession pour célébrer
cette année difficile on n'a pas
eu de rassemblement. On peut
visiter cette caverne d'Ali
Baba. Voici mon reportage.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Jean Daniel Rohrer est
un peintre à succès.
Originaire de Suisse,
il est installé au Québec
depuis une trentaine d'années.
Membre de l'Académie royale
des arts du Canada, ses tableaux
ont été exposés un peu partout
sur la planète et se vendent
des milliers de dollars.
Le peintre s'est lancé un
nouveau défi : la sculpture.
JEAN-DANIEL ROHRER, artiste
- J'ai souvent des personnages
filiformes qui habitent un peu
tout mon travail, et puis en
les mettant en volume et tout,
c'est un ensemble de
personnages. Oui, c'est pour
une procession, puis c'est un
peu une pensée en fonction
des temps troubles dans lesquels
on vit actuellement.
- Il y aura au total 50
sculptures, toutes uniques
qui formeront une procession.
- Un genre de rituel heureux,
une commémoration, une
revendication au bonheur
par tous mes personnages
qui vont créer ce défilé.
- Des sculptures faites de
matériel ferroviaire glané
sur le site de l'ancienne gare
de triage Outremont devenu
le campus MIL de l'Université de
Montréal.
- Je commence toujours par une
pièce centrale, une pièce de
référence et ensuite au gré du
matériel que j'ai, bien,
forcément avec les clous,
c'est les pieds et les têtes,
puis là, je construis
en fonction du matériel que j'ai
un corps et il apparaît.
- Pour créer cette procession,
il collabore avec son ami,
le sculpteur Olivier Martineau.
OLIVIER MARTINEAU, artiste
- De réussir à échanger
avec quelqu'un d'autre
dans la création, pour moi,
c'est un des plus beaux moments
que je peux récolter.
- Et il partage son envie de
sculpter un monde meilleur,
en donnant des ateliers
dans les écoles dans le cadre
du Festival TransAmériques.
- Actuellement, on perd tous
nos repères et tout, donc il
faut avoir cette faculté-là
d'imaginer d'autres choses
dans le futur et pas s'accrocher
dans le passé.
- Lorsque les 50 statuettes
seront terminées, il organisera
une procession carnavalesque
où le grand public sera invité.
Des rituels qui font cruellement
défaut par les temps qui
courent.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.